what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
7 update video The Game of Thrones
community is buzzing right now after
Entertainment Weekly just posted several
new photos that were taking during the
filming of season 7 I don't want to
waste any of your time today so let's
get right into this comment below and
tell me what you think is going on in
each of these new photos the first photo
was of the marriage Targaryen and would
you look at the size of her dragon
drogon I mean holy [ __ ] a report did
come out a few weeks ago that said
Daenerys dragons would be the size of
747 airplanes well it doesn't look like
they were kidding worthy Daenerys looks
so small on the back of drove on right
now it's kind of hilarious but this is a
spectacular image this is most likely
the scene that was mentioned in the plot
leaked apparently at some point next
season Daenerys is supposed to ambush
Jaime Lannister and has Lannister army
as they are marching back from
Highgarden we've seen a few photos from
this battlefield already Daenerys is
supposed to kill Randall and dick on
Tarly next season with her dragons Jaime
Lannister is also supposed to be nearly
killed as well until he is saved by
Bronn it's hard to say if all these
details are going to be correct or not
but I absolutely believe this image will
be from the battle that's going to take
place midseason which is kind of crazy
for Game of Thrones standards they
typically feature their biggest battle
scenes at the end of the seasons usually
during episode 9 each year but the
director that has been seen on set
filming these battle scenes is the same
director that's going to be directing
episodes 4 & 5 so we can potentially get
a midseason battle that's supposed to be
the biggest battle Game of Thrones has
ever done
they hired hundreds of extras and nearly
100 horses were brought on set to film
these scenes which is more than what
they used for the Battle of the bastards
and by the look of this photo I think
we're going to be in store for something
even more epic now that Daenerys dragons
will be involved in these battles I
cannot wait for this scene to take place
can you imagine Jon Snow in the middle
of a battle with Dany's dragons flying
over top of him providing aerial support
I think that would be absolutely amazing
but let's move on to the next photo
though which is a photo of Jon Snow on
horseback he appears to be leaving
Winterfell in my opinion if you look at
his hand it does appear that he is
waving goodbye to someone
most likely waving goodbye to Sansa I
think this is one
Neely's wonderful to head south and meet
up with Daenerys Targaryen on
Dragonstone but let me know what you
think's going on here if you think
something else is going on comment down
below but to me it appears that he is
indeed leaving wonderful which I think
we all knew what happened at some point
next season we know he needs dragonglass
and we know he needs men in order for
him to acquire these things he's going
to have to leave Winterfell and make
some moves the next photo is of songs of
Stark and Littlefinger this is the exact
same scene taking place that we got a
glimpse of last time HBO released a few
photos this is just a different angle
taken from the courtyard of Winterfell I
think this is going to take place after
John is gone and goes down to
Dragonstone which I think Littlefinger
is going to see as an opportunity to try
and manipulate songs even more and get
her to turn against John Littlefinger
need songs are in control of the north
because he assumes she will be much
easier to deal with than John but in my
opinion Littlefinger is going to be in
for a big surprise next season when the
student songs a stark surpasses the
teacher Petyr Baelish I think songs is
going to end up al playing Littlefinger
at his own game what should eventually
lead to him being exposed and ultimately
executed as cool of a character that
Littlefinger is I think we are all
patiently waiting for the day to come to
where he must pay for his crimes and
it's going to be glorious the next photo
is in the throne room at King's Landing
once again this is the same scene that
we got a peek at recently when HBO
released their previous photos this is
just a different angle of Cersei and
Jaime Lannister most likely meeting with
someone I think this is when Cersei and
Euron meet for the first time and
discuss their terms of an alliance we
know from other photos that your own is
going to arrive in King's Landing with a
few prisoners that Cersei would love to
get her hands on not to mention Cersei
and Euron both need a new alliance so
it's going to be a perfect fit for these
two psychos to come together and wreak
some more havoc before their inevitable
deaths but comment below if you think
something else is going on here - I'd
love to hear what you have to say about
this in the next photo is of Arya Stark
riding on horseback and I must say even
though Arya and Ned Stark aren't related
in real life it's almost scary how
similar co-op store father now I mean
Arya is a spitting image of Ned it's
crazy how much they actually look alike
they did a hell of a job casting these
two to be family members but anyway I
think this is going to be one of the
most emotional scenes next season
because I think this could be Oreo
arriving in
or so with the stark theme playing in
the background and Aria arriving and
standing within water fills walls again
it's going to be so emotional and
satisfying to see her make it home I'm
really looking forward to this scene and
the next photo shows Korman standing in
Winterfell and I'm not sure exactly
what's going on here this could be the
same scene where John leaves Winterfell
for Dragonstone this could just be
torment seeing John off as he leaves but
I can't guarantee that of course but it
does appear that Brienne and standing in
the back they're wearing her armor so we
do know that Breen makes it back to
Winterfell in one piece which is a good
thing
and speaking of brand the last photo is
a brand of Tora who looks to be very
happy in this scene even though they're
not actually filming at this time but
she better hold on to this thought
because we know that much darker days
are on the horizon now that winter is
here and I'm not too sure what's going
on in this photo either to be honest
with you there isn't really much to go
on here this could also be at Winterfell
but I don't remember seeing those small
curtains there before so maybe they
added that for the season or perhaps she
could be somewhere else if you have
anything to add to this photo let me
know down in the comments
I always appreciate those of you that
can pick up on a few details that I
might have missed but that's going to do
it for today folks I got to cut this
video kind of short I'm sorry I didn't
get it out a little bit sooner to you
I'm actually at work right now but as
soon as I received these photos I
immediately took my lunch break that way
I could record this and get it out to
you as soon as possible thanks for
stopping by and watching this video
thank you to all my patreon supporters
as well I love all you guys and I'll see
you down below bye